Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. History never repeats itself, but it rhymes, said Mark Twain. In which case, can we truly learn from history? And if we can, do we? Here on The Rest Is History, we like to focus up very close on Bronze Age Anatolia or the summer of 1981. But we also like to focus on the truly
感谢收听《历史的余韵》。想要获取每周的加更节目、无广告收听体验、抢先收听系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。马克·吐温曾说，历史不会重演，但会押韵。既然如此，我们真的能从历史中学习吗？如果能，我们真的学到了吗？在《历史的余韵》中，我们喜欢近距离聚焦青铜时代的安纳托利亚或1981年的夏天。但我们也喜欢聚焦于真正
big questions. And for big questions, we need a big historian with a big brain. Dominic Sandbrook, good to have you back. A big head anyway. Listeners, yes, yes, a big head. Listeners, you can feel free to write your own jokes in as well. Dominic, how's your week been? In mourning for Maradona? I know you're a big fan. I am sad about Maradona, actually. Maradona was a great character and I do think he was a great... Oh gosh, we did greatness, didn't we, in our first episode? I do think he was a great... He's a great figure, isn't he? He's a great figure in Argentine history. He's a great figure in footballing history. He's probably the greatest footballer in terms of dragging his team to the World Cup.
宏大的问题。而对于宏大的问题，我们需要一位拥有大智慧的伟大历史学家。多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，很高兴你回来。反正头很大。听众们，是的，是的，头很大。听众们，你们也可以随意写下你们自己的笑话。多米尼克，你这周过得怎么样？是在为马拉多纳哀悼吗？我知道你是他的超级粉丝。我确实为马拉多纳感到难过。马拉多纳是一个伟大的人物，我确实认为他是一位伟大的……哦天哪，我们在第一集里讨论过“伟大”，不是吗？我确实认为他是一位伟大的……他是一位伟大的人物，不是吗？他是阿根廷历史上的一位伟大人物。他是足球史上的一位伟大人物。就带领球队夺得世界杯而言，他可能是最伟大的足球运动员。
So yeah, I am in mourning for Maradona. Maradona the great. Right, before we get to our topic for discussion today, let's check out some of your comments on last week's podcast in which we travelled back to Troy and discussed what makes it such an enduring legend. Brilliant comment here from listener Fergus Michael John. Don't we all like Hector because he's a real hero, not divinely protected like Achilles? Yeah, so Achilles is a cheat. He doesn't spend his time sulking in his tent. He fights for his people. We can't be Achilles, but we could aspire to be Hector. Yeah, I'd agree with that. I think that Hector behaves very well in the Iliad, doesn't he? I mean, he's a noble hero
所以，是的，我正在为马拉多纳哀悼。伟大的马拉多纳。好了，在进入今天的话题之前，让我们来看看你们对上周播客的一些评论，在那期节目中，我们回到了特洛伊，讨论了是什么让它成为一个经久不衰的传说。听众弗格斯·迈克尔·约翰的评论非常精彩。难道我们不都喜欢赫克托耳吗？因为他是一个真正的英雄，不像阿喀琉斯那样有神灵庇护？是的，所以阿喀琉斯是个骗子。他没有把时间花在帐篷里生闷气。他为他的人民而战。我们成不了阿喀琉斯，但我们可以立志成为赫克托耳。是的，我同意这一点。我认为赫克托耳在《伊利亚特》中的表现非常好，不是吗？我的意思是，他是一位高尚的英雄，
who says goodbye to his wife and child, and he goes out to do his bit for his country, as it were, or his city. There's not all this kind of moaning and gro goodbye to his wife and child and he goes out to do his bit for his country, as it were, or his city. There's not all this kind of moaning and groaning about slave girls and crying and just sort of being a bit of a wet blanket like Achilles. Do you not agree? No, I think the fact that Achilles is appalling is precisely what makes him such a brilliant hero, actually. I think he's so great that he doesn't have to be held to normal standards. Oh, that's terrible. Yeah, I can see why you like John Lennon.
他向妻子和孩子告别，然后走出去为他的国家，或者说他的城市尽自己的一份力。他没有那种关于女奴的抱怨和哭泣，也没有像阿喀琉斯那样表现得像个扫兴的人。你不同意吗？不，我认为阿喀琉斯令人震惊的事实恰恰使他成为一个如此出色的英雄。我认为他太伟大了，以至于不必遵守常规标准。哦，那太糟糕了。是的，我明白你为什么喜欢约翰·列侬了。
Right, Mikhail Tavaridis, he said, a great episode about a great topic. I think the Iliad is the best book for opening the gates to further interest in mythology and history, not only of the Greek variety, at least it was for me. Was the Iliad a great gateway for you, Tom? Yeah, I think the Greek legends generally, the heroes and things. I think i was kind
好的，米哈伊尔·塔瓦里迪斯说，关于一个伟大话题的伟大一集。我认为《伊利亚特》是开启对神话和历史进一步兴趣的最佳书籍，不仅是希腊神话，至少对我来说是这样。汤姆，《伊利亚特》对你来说是一个伟大的入门书吗？是的，我认为希腊传说通常是这样，英雄之类的。我想我大概
of a perseus and heracles man first before before i got onto the trojan war but yeah yeah it's it's the gateway drug no question about it um and uh c bb mf i hope i've got those initials right um he contend that's to say loved the episode strange how troy the filmmakers of troy failed to realize achilles isn't a hero to the modern world. So he's agreeing with you, Dominic. A sullen, capricious glory seeker. Everyone rooting for Hector because he comes out with the Christian virtues you mentioned. That's me.
在接触特洛伊战争之前，先是珀尔修斯和赫拉克勒斯的粉丝，但确实，毫无疑问，它是入门毒品。嗯，还有C BB MF，我希望我没记错这些首字母，嗯，他认为，也就是说，很喜欢这一集。奇怪的是，《特洛伊》的电影制作人竟然没意识到阿喀琉斯在现代世界并不是一个英雄。所以他同意你的观点，多米尼克。一个阴郁、反复无常的荣耀追求者。每个人都支持赫克托耳，因为他展现了你提到的基督教美德。那就是我。
So good. He's agreeing with both of us. That's the kind of response we like. And we've got Pepin Lucker who said, not one but two Duran Duran references. Excellent. Yes, those references were like a river twisting across a dusty land. Oh, Tom, let me bring you back to planet Earth.
太棒了。他同意我们两个人的观点。这就是我们喜欢的反馈。我们还有佩平·卢克，他说，不是一个，而是两个杜兰杜兰乐队的梗。太棒了。是的，那些梗就像一条蜿蜒穿过尘土飞扬土地的河流。哦，汤姆，让我把你带回地球。
We've got to stop this. We've got to cancel this. Right then, we're having our very own existential crisis this morning, and it's not about Duran Duran references. It's about the big one. Does history matter? the big one does history matter do we learn from it can we learn from it um Dominic I want a thousand words on the subject by the end of this podcast 15 mark question actually now I'm going to give you 30 marks because it is a very difficult one oh that's kind thank you um does it matter do we learn from it can we learn from it uh we don't well we learn something but we don't it doesn't make us better and it doesn't furnish um neat moralistic lessons i think now the idea that there's lessons in history i mean that goes back to the greeks and the romans doesn't it so you think about pluto's lives come on we haven't we're not going to get into christianity yet by the way
我们得停止这个。我们得取消这个。好了，今天早上我们正经历着我们自己的存在主义危机，这与杜兰杜兰的梗无关。这是关于那个大问题。历史重要吗？那个大问题，历史重要吗？我们能从中学习吗？我们能从中学习吗？嗯，多米尼克，我希望在这期播客结束时，你能写出一千字关于这个主题的文章。15分的问题，实际上现在我要给你30分，因为它非常困难。哦，你真好，谢谢。嗯，它重要吗？我们能从中学习吗？我们能从中学习吗？嗯，我们不……好吧，我们学到了一些东西，但我们没有……它并没有让我们变得更好，也没有提供……简洁的道德教训。我想现在，历史中有教训的想法，我的意思是，这可以追溯到希腊人和罗马人，不是吗？所以你想到普鲁塔克的《名人传》，来吧，我们还没打算讨论基督教，顺便说一句。
let's shelve that until the second half at least. If maybe save Christianity for the extended edition, which you can send to your personal followers on some sort of dark web link. But are there neat lessons? No, there aren't. People draw the lessons I think they want to draw, don't they? I mean, I don't think there are. Nobody ever draws a lesson from history
让我们至少把那个留到下半场。如果可以的话，把基督教留给加长版，你可以通过某种暗网链接发送给你的个人粉丝。但有简洁的教训吗？不，没有。我认为人们会得出他们想得出的教训，不是吗？我的意思是，我不认为有。从来没有人会从历史中得出
they didn't want to draw in the first place. I think there's a confused mass of stuff and people impose their own patterns on it and they tease out, they seek justification in history for what they wanted to do anyway. That's my short answer. So when you say confused mass, I think that the lesson we learn from history is the one that Gregory of Tor famously opens his history of the Franks with when he's writing in the late sixth century. The best opening, I think, not just any history book, but any book ever. And he says a great many things keep happening. Some of them good, some of them bad. That's all history. That's that's that's the lesson of history, isn't it? Stuff happens. Some of it's good, some of it's bad. Can we say more than that? It's interesting, isn't it, that when people
他们最初不想得出的教训。我认为这是一堆混乱的东西，人们把自己的模式强加在上面，他们挖掘出来，他们为自己无论如何都想做的事情在历史中寻求正当性。这是我的简短回答。所以当你说是混乱的一团时，我认为我们从历史中学习到的教训是图尔的格雷戈里在六世纪末撰写《法兰克人史》时著名的开篇。我认为这是最好的开篇，不仅仅是任何历史书，而是任何书。他说，很多事情一直在发生。有些是好的，有些是坏的。这就是历史。这就是历史的教训，不是吗？事情发生了。有些是好的，有些是坏的。我们能说得更多吗？这很有趣，不是吗，当人们
seek to write history, they've always generally sought to sort of tease out some kind of lesson. So, you know, for a long time, the story of history was the deeds of great men and what lesson can future, you know, future leaders learn. So that was why history was written in many ways. It was for sort of educated elite people to learn the mistakes of, I don't know, Mark Antony or somebody and to make sure they don't. I mean, often history is sort of the story of the puncturing of hubris. I mean, that seems such a sort of recurrent theme. Now, the interesting thing is that I don't think we have abandoned that. So now I think, I mean, you see this so much in all the discussion about history and decolonization and statues and
寻求撰写历史时，他们通常总是试图挖掘出某种教训。所以，你知道，很长一段时间以来，历史的故事就是伟人的事迹，未来的领导人能学到什么教训。所以这就是历史在许多方面被撰写的原因。它是为了让受过教育的精英阶层学习马克·安东尼或其他人的错误，并确保他们不会犯同样的错误。我的意思是，历史通常是关于傲慢被刺破的故事。我的意思是，这似乎是一个反复出现的主题。现在，有趣的是，我不认为我们已经放弃了这一点。所以现在我想，我的意思是，你在所有关于历史、去殖民化和雕像的讨论中看到了很多，
all the rest of it. People want, they still look to history to furnish kind of ideological, for sort of ideological support, I guess, don't they? So they look to history and they say, the story of history is a series of inspiring examples, and we can learn the lesson of how these people fought against oppression or whatever it might be. Yeah, I think that's right. I think history, traditionally, going right the way back to the beginning and right the way up to the present, is about examples that we can follow, lessons that we can learn in that sense. But can I go back to the ancient Greeks? I mean, I know it's very, very, very in our time to do that. You always have to start if you're in our time with the Greeks.
以及所有其他的事情。人们想要，他们仍然指望历史来提供某种意识形态的，为了某种意识形态的支持，我想，不是吗？所以他们看向历史，他们说，历史的故事是一系列鼓舞人心的例子，我们可以学习这些人如何反抗压迫或任何其他事情的教训。是的，我认为那是对的。我认为历史，传统上，一直追溯到开始，一直延续到今天，是关于我们可以遵循的例子，在那种意义上我们可以学习的教训。但我能回到古希腊人那里吗？我的意思是，我知道在我们的时代这样做是非常、非常、非常流行的。如果你在我们的时代，你总是必须从希腊人开始。
But if you if you look at Thucydides, who is kind of the archetype of this kind of historian, somebody who says very deliberately that he's writing this book to be not just for the now, but to be a possession for all time. And when you look now at, say, West Point or military academies or foreign affairs centres in universities, they're very keen on Thucydides because they look at him and they say yeah there are actual lessons here so the classic one that's very popular at the moment in relation to America and China is what they call the Thucydides trap which is the idea that um a set power a set superpower is going to be menaced by another power coming up on the tracks so Sparta is menaced by
但如果你看看修昔底德，他是这种历史学家的原型，一个非常刻意地说他写这本书不仅是为了现在，而是为了成为永恒的财富的人。当你现在看看，比如说西点军校或军事学院或大学里的外交事务中心，他们非常热衷于修昔底德，因为他们看着他，他们说，是的，这里确实有实际的教训。所以目前与美国和中国有关的非常流行的经典例子是他们所说的“修昔底德陷阱”，即一个既定的超级大国将受到另一个正在崛起的强权的威胁，所以斯巴达受到
uh by Athens um Britain was menaced by Germany before the tracks. So Sparta is menaced by Athens. Britain was menaced by Germany before the First World War. America is now menaced by China. And so they extrapolate from this the idea that you can find in Thucydides, and I suppose by extension, every work of history, kind of hard lessons that can be applied in any situation. But I think that that is certainly to misunderstand Thucydides. And it's to understand the nature of history generally, because actually Thucydides is never saying that the left that I'm not. You know, he's not giving hard and cast lessons. What he's doing is flagging up situations that then will be contingent. So another famous lesson that supposedly Thucydides gives, and again, it's much quoted at the moment, is the idea that the strong do as they wish and the weak have to put up with it. And this again is in the kind of the context of the Peloponnesian War. The Athenians
雅典的威胁……英国在第一次世界大战前受到德国的威胁。美国现在受到中国的威胁。因此，他们从中推断出你在修昔底德中可以找到的想法，我想推而广之，每一部历史著作，某种可以应用于任何情况的硬教训。但我认为这肯定是对修昔底德的误解。而且是对历史本质的普遍误解，因为实际上修昔底德从来没有说过……你知道，他没有给出硬性的教训。他所做的是标记出那些随后会具有偶然性的情况。所以修昔底德据称给出的另一个著名的教训，同样，目前被广泛引用，是强者为所欲为，弱者必须忍受的想法。而这再次是在伯罗奔尼撒战争的背景下。雅典人
are about to attack the island of Melos and incinerate it. But the paradox of that is that this is going to then encourage the Athenians to invade Sicily and basically lose the war. So the Athenians misunderstand their own lesson. And I think that that's kind of the risk, isn't it? Is that if you extrapolate hard, solid lessons from history, then you're going to misinterpret them. Well, there are some excellent examples of that, Tom. And actually, when you talk about West Point and sort of military academies, I think they're some of the worst people drawing these lessons, aren't they? I mean, the classic one is the lesson of appeasement.
正准备攻击米洛斯岛并将其烧毁。但其中的悖论是，这将鼓励雅典人入侵西西里岛并基本上输掉战争。所以雅典人误解了他们自己的教训。我认为这就是风险，不是吗？如果你从历史中推断出硬性的、坚实的教训，那么你就会误解它们。嗯，有一些很好的例子，汤姆。实际上，当你谈论西点军校和军事学院时，我认为他们是得出这些教训的最糟糕的人，不是吗？我的意思是，经典的一个是绥靖政策的教训。
I mean, that's the sort of, we've talked a lot about the sort of, the way in which the world wars have become a myth, and they've become a sort of foundational myth of 21st century civilization. And time and again, sort of politicians and colonists reach for appeasement, which they completely misunderstand as a policy of sort of flabby, you know, weakness and what are just sort of they think that the appeasers were just cowards. And that the lesson of appeasement is that you have any sort of strongman or anybody that you don't like. And if you don't stand up to them, then they will take over the world and all the rest of it. And you heard this a lot in America in the 1960s,
我的意思是，那是那种……我们谈论了很多关于世界大战如何成为一种神话，它们已经成为21世纪文明的一种基础神话。一次又一次，政客和专栏作家伸手去拿绥靖政策，他们完全将其误解为一种软弱的政策，你知道，他们认为绥靖者只是懦夫。绥靖政策的教训是，如果你有任何强人或任何你不喜欢的人。如果你不站出来反对他们，那么他们就会接管世界等等。你在20世纪60年代的美国听到了很多，
in the Kennedy and Johnson White Houses and in the National Security Council and whatnot. They would sit around and they would say, we can't be Britain in the 1930s. We have to send more troops to Vietnam. We have to roll back communism. We must stand up to them and all the rest of it. And then, of course, Iraq. Right. Iraq. Iraq is the other time. So Tony Blair and George Bush, they talk about appeasement a lot and they say the lesson of history is you stand up to dictators. And Britain has its own experience
在肯尼迪和约翰逊的白宫，以及国家安全委员会等等。他们会坐在一起说，我们不能成为20世纪30年代的英国。我们必须向越南派遣更多军队。我们必须击退共产主义。我们必须站出来反对他们等等。然后，当然，伊拉克。对。伊拉克。伊拉克是另一个例子。所以托尼·布莱尔和乔治·布什，他们谈论了很多绥靖政策，他们说历史的教训是你站出来反对独裁者。而英国有自己的经验
of making this terrible decision with Suez. So I think that's the first time actually that Suez in 1956, where the appeasement sort of metaphor was really dragged into action. Anthony Eden, who had lived through appeasement, said, Colonel Nasser, the nationalist leader of Egypt, who's nationalized the Suez Canal, he is Mussolini. He is another Mussolini. And we must stand up. He wasn't. He was just a Nasser. And I think that tendency, that sort of lesson of history temptation, is that you say Donald Trump actually is Adolf Hitler. And, you know, that's the sort of history repeating itself stuff, isn't it? Which I never believe that history repeats itself. Yeah, I think the tendency to accuse your enemies of being Hitler is, I mean, it's not so much a lesson, is it? It's a kind of spasm. It's a sort of knee-jerk thing, isn't it?
在苏伊士运河问题上做出这个可怕的决定。所以我认为这实际上是第一次，1956年的苏伊士运河，绥靖政策的隐喻被真正付诸行动。安东尼·艾登，他经历过绥靖政策，说埃及的民族主义领导人纳赛尔上校，他将苏伊士运河国有化了，他是墨索里尼。他是另一个墨索里尼。我们必须站出来。他不是。他只是一个纳赛尔。我认为这种倾向，那种历史教训的诱惑，就是你说唐纳德·特朗普实际上是阿道夫·希特勒。而且，你知道，这就是历史重演的东西，不是吗？我从来不相信历史会重演。是的，我认为指责你的敌人是希特勒的倾向，我的意思是，这与其说是一个教训，不如说是一种痉挛。这是一种膝跳反应，不是吗？
This is how Nazi Germany started. So maybe one of the lessons of history is that people aren't actually Hitler. Well, nobody is Hitler, by definition. I mean, other than Hitler. But it's funny, isn't it, how people... It's a good way of closing down an argument, right? That you say, well, this is Nazis and this is Hitler. But it's funny, isn't it, how people, it's a good way of closing down an argument, right? That you say, well, this is Nazis and this is Hitler, therefore evil, therefore we must immediately, you know, throw our hands in the air and intervene or do whatever.
这就是纳粹德国开始的方式。所以也许历史的教训之一是人们实际上并不是希特勒。好吧，根据定义，没有人是希特勒。我的意思是，除了希特勒。但这很有趣，不是吗，人们……这是一个结束争论的好方法，对吧？你说，好吧，这是纳粹，这是希特勒。但这很有趣，不是吗，人们……这是一个结束争论的好方法，对吧？你说，好吧，这是纳粹，这是希特勒，因此是邪恶的，因此我们必须立即，你知道，举手投降并进行干预或做任何事情。
It's an interest, but it's interesting the extent to which we are kind of historically conditioned. So we can't talk about issues without reaching back to history for precedence and for, you know, you can't consider things purely on their own merit. So Donald Trump can't just be Donald Trump. He has to be compared with the dictators of the 1930s or sort of 19th century populists or whatever. There is another way in which, again, looking back to the Greeks, you can, perhaps people have drawn lessons from history, and that's to kind of identify patterns within it. So Thucydides kind of, you know, he sets out the idea that if you study the past, you can draw lessons for politics. But Herodotus, his predecessor, he is, and you mentioned the importance of hubris. Basically, in Herodotus, there's this
这很有趣，但我们被历史条件化的程度很有趣。所以我们不能在不回顾历史以寻找先例的情况下讨论问题，你知道，你不能纯粹根据它们自身的优点来考虑事情。所以唐纳德·特朗普不能仅仅是唐纳德·特朗普。他必须与20世纪30年代的独裁者或19世纪的民粹主义者等等进行比较。还有另一种方式，再次回顾希腊人，你可以，也许人们已经从历史中吸取了教训，那就是在其中识别模式。所以修昔底德，你知道，他提出了如果你研究过去，你就可以为政治吸取教训的想法。但希罗多德，他的前任，他，你提到了傲慢的重要性。基本上，在希罗多德那里，有这个
idea that history generates a pattern, that you have people who are hungry, people who are poor, people who live on the margins, they're tough. And they see wealthy cities, wealthy empires, and these wealthy empires become soft. and the hungry, lean people can move in and they take over and then they become wealthy and they become soft and then more hungry people move in. And you get this cycle going on and on. And it's interesting because that's basically the idea that you get in Ibn Khaldun as well, the great medieval Muslim historian, who likewise kind of traces this pattern that people on the periphery will inevitably move in on the great settled centres. So does that, I mean, I don't know, do you think
想法，历史产生了一种模式，你有饥饿的人，贫穷的人，生活在边缘的人，他们很坚韧。他们看到富裕的城市，富裕的帝国，而这些富裕的帝国变得软弱。而饥饿、瘦弱的人可以搬进来，他们接管了，然后他们变得富有，他们变得软弱，然后更多饥饿的人搬进来。你让这个循环不断进行。这很有趣，因为这基本上也是伊本·赫勒敦，伟大的中世纪穆斯林历史学家所持有的观点，他同样追踪了这种模式，即边缘的人将不可避免地进入伟大的定居中心。那么，我的意思是，我不知道，你认为
that there's any value in tracing those kind of patterns through history in the way that Herodotus and Ibn Khaldun did? I suppose it's kind of element of Marxism there, isn't there as well? There is. I mean, yeah, these things are not... I mean, they're sort of structurally driven, aren't they? That you get a... I mean, I think that is a reasonable sort of... I don't think it's a stretch to say that a lean and hungry generation claws its way to power and then gives way to a sort of a fatter and less hungry one. I mean, you're just sort of viewing one's contemporaries. You can see how self-made people classically will have children who are less driven because they're all the rest of it. That's true of societies as well. I think you can see that.
追踪历史中那些模式有任何价值吗，就像希罗多德和伊本·赫勒敦那样？我想那里也有马克思主义的成分，不是吗？确实有。我的意思是，是的，这些事情不是……我的意思是，它们是结构性驱动的，不是吗？你得到一个……我的意思是，我认为这是一个合理的……我不认为说一代瘦弱饥饿的人通过努力获得权力，然后让位于一代更肥胖、饥饿感更少的人是一种夸张。我的意思是，你只是在观察同时代的人。你可以看到白手起家的人通常会有动力不足的孩子，因为他们拥有所有其他东西。这对社会也是如此。我认为你可以看到这一点。
And you can see, I think it would be weird to deny that you can look at particular situations and see patterns recurring. I mean, if you were, for instance, if you studied both the French Revolution and the Russian Revolution, it would be perverse, I think. I mean, of course, they're different, but it'd be perverse to say there's no pattern whatsoever. There's no similarity at all between Louis XVI and Nicholas II or between, you know, the Girondins and the Mensheviks or something.
而且你可以看到，我认为否认你可以观察特定情况并看到反复出现的模式是奇怪的。我的意思是，如果你，例如，如果你同时研究法国大革命和俄国革命，我认为那是反常的。我的意思是，当然，它们是不同的，但说它们之间没有任何模式是反常的。路易十六和尼古拉二世之间，或者，你知道，吉伦特派和孟什维克之间，或者类似的人之间，根本没有任何相似之处。
But isn't that because both the French and the Russian revolutions are essentially generated from the same kind of ideological mulch. That their blooms from the same, you know, they're drawing, I'm not allowed to talk about Christianity, but I'm going to. They're drawing on kind of deeply rooted Christian assumptions about the idea that the first will be last and the last will be first and that there'll be a kind of millennial reckoning when the sheep will be divided from the goats and that kind of thing. Yeah. So you don't get, I mean, but you don't get revolutions. It's about the logic of revolution, isn't it? I mean, that's what happens in a revolution.
但那不是因为法国大革命和俄国革命本质上都是由同一种意识形态覆盖物产生的吗？它们从同一种，你知道，它们正在汲取，我不被允许谈论基督教，但我还是要谈。它们正在汲取关于“首先将是最后，最后将是首先”以及将会有某种千禧年清算，羊将与山羊分开之类的深刻根植的基督教假设。是的。所以你没有，我的意思是，但你没有革命。这是关于革命的逻辑，不是吗？我的意思是，这就是革命中发生的事情。
Yeah. But revolutions are culturally specific. I mean, do you get revolutions like that in Mesoamerica or in China before Mao? I mean, I don't think so, because I think that the lessons of history, maybe they're very precise if you're looking at specific cultural contexts. But the broader issue, I guess, is are there universal lessons that apply kind of across the entire span? No, I'd say no. Not on a social level. Okay, so looking at the Herodotus Ibn Khaldun idea, it's a very materialist idea. The idea that ultimately there are people who live on the periphery who inevitably will come in because they don't have stuff that they want. But doesn't that also work in a context though, Tom? Isn't that also historically specific that you're talking about, you know, they're both talking about a particular place, the sort of, you know, Eurasia and all the rest of it. Yes. Well, specifically it works, I mean, it works with deserts, doesn't it? And the steps and the idea that you have kind of
是的。但革命是文化特定的。我的意思是，你在中美洲或毛泽东之前的中国有那样的革命吗？我的意思是，我不这么认为，因为我认为历史的教训，也许如果你看特定的文化背景，它们是非常精确的。但更广泛的问题，我想是，是否有适用于整个跨度的普遍教训？不，我会说没有。在社会层面上没有。好吧，所以看看希罗多德和伊本·赫勒敦的想法，这是一个非常唯物主义的想法。认为最终有生活在边缘的人，他们不可避免地会进来，因为他们没有他们想要的东西。但这在背景中也有效吗，汤姆？那不是历史特定的吗，你谈论的是，你知道，他们都在谈论一个特定的地方，那种，你知道，欧亚大陆等等。是的。好吧，具体来说它有效，我的意思是，它在沙漠中有效，不是吗？还有草原，以及你拥有某种
centres of urban civilisation and then you have kind of peripheries. But the converse of that, again, to turn it on its head, is that very settled sedentary civilizations are likely to be more powerful than those that aren't. So a Spaniard arriving in Central America in the early 16th century brings with him thousands of years of sedentary civilization and the Aztecs don't have that um and in that context actually you could say that Ibn Khaldun's got it exactly wrong but that it's always those from the wealthy centers that will triumph but that doesn't work does it look at the Mongols look at the Mongols I mean they built the greatest land empire in history they swept through everybody. And they were your classic steppe nomads coming to sedentary societies to sort of settled, you know, European or Asian sacking places like Baghdad, going into Poland and Hungary and all the rest of it.
城市文明中心，然后你有某种边缘的想法。但反过来，再次将其颠倒过来，是非常定居的文明可能比那些不定居的文明更强大。所以一个16世纪初到达中美洲的西班牙人带来了数千年的定居文明，而阿兹特克人没有那个，嗯，在这种背景下，实际上你可以说伊本·赫勒敦完全错了，但总是那些来自富裕中心的人会获胜，但这行不通，不是吗？看看蒙古人，看看蒙古人，我的意思是，他们建立了历史上最大的陆地帝国，他们横扫了所有人。他们是你典型的草原游牧民族，来到定居社会，来到定居的，你知道，欧洲或亚洲，洗劫像巴格达这样的地方，进入波兰和匈牙利等等。
I mean, the Mongols are the classic kind of Ibn Khaldun outsiders, aren't they? They're on the margins. They're nomads, steppe horsemen, and no one can resist them. They are, but you could say that maybe the lesson of history is that nomads will be absorbed and essentially take on the contours of the civilizations that they conquer. So, you know, I mean, the Mongols basically became Chinese. And that just doesn't seem to me like a very, I mean, a very surprising or compelling lesson, though. I mean, that just doesn't seem to me like a very, I mean, a very surprising or compelling lesson, though. I mean, that just seems to me like, I mean, sometimes a lesson from history just strikes me as plain common sense. So, for example, the point about, you know, a self-made, a sort of rapacious self-made man then has a lazy, spoiled, self-indulgent son. I mean, I don't think you need to have sort of poured through the records of history to work that one out, surely. But what about the kind of the Jared Diamond
我的意思是，蒙古人是典型的伊本·赫勒敦式的局外人，不是吗？他们在边缘。他们是游牧民族，草原骑兵，没有人能抵抗他们。他们是，但你可以说也许历史的教训是游牧民族将被吸收，并基本上采取他们征服的文明的轮廓。所以，你知道，我的意思是，蒙古人基本上变成了中国人。但这对我来说似乎不是一个非常，我的意思是，一个非常令人惊讶或引人注目的教训。我的意思是，这对我来说似乎不是一个非常，我的意思是，一个非常令人惊讶或引人注目的教训。我的意思是，这对我来说似乎就像，我的意思是，有时历史的教训让我觉得是纯粹的常识。所以，例如，关于，你知道，一个白手起家、贪婪的白手起家的人然后有一个懒惰、被宠坏、自我放纵的儿子的观点。我的意思是，我不认为你需要翻阅历史记录来弄清楚这一点，肯定不需要。但关于那种贾里德·戴蒙德
perspective, the sense that the achievements of a given civilization essentially are dependent on material circumstances. They're dependent on what crops you may have, what animals you can domesticate, what reservoirs of raw materials you have. And that's the determinant. I mean, now those are lessons that Jared Diamond would say, these are hardcore lessons. He would. And you've now hit upon one of my great sort of, one of the things I really hate about history, which are books that claim guns germs steel and whatever 112 lessons and how democracies die how the west rose all this kind of thing those books i mean i always associate all those books with a sort of the airport bookstore in milwaukee or something and i think those are books that are
的视角，那种认为一个给定文明的成就本质上取决于物质环境的感觉。它们取决于你可能有什么作物，你可以驯化什么动物，你有什么原材料储备。而那是决定因素。我的意思是，现在那些是贾里德·戴蒙德会说的教训，这些是硬核教训。他会。而你现在触及了我非常讨厌历史的一件事，那就是那些声称《枪炮、病菌与钢铁》以及无论什么112个教训，以及民主如何死亡，西方如何崛起等等的书。那些书，我的意思是，我总是把所有这些书与某种在密尔沃基的机场书店之类的东西联系起来，我认为那些书是
for american businessmen who've they've lost their charger they've got a two-hour flight to kansas city they need something to read, and here is a book that they think will give them all the lessons of history. They can boil it down to a 12-point TED talk, and at the end of it, they'll know all history, they'll know what's going to happen, because that's what all these books always do. They say, we have studied the past, and we've boiled it down to this sort of PowerPoint presentation, and now we know what's going to happen in the 23rd century. And I find all that stuff, personally, I hate all that stuff.
为那些丢失了充电器、有两小时飞往堪萨斯城航班的美国商人准备的，他们需要读点什么，而这里有一本书，他们认为会给他们所有的历史教训。他们可以将其浓缩成一个12点的TED演讲，在最后，他们会知道所有的历史，他们会知道将会发生什么，因为这就是所有这些书总是做的。他们说，我们研究了过去，我们将其浓缩成这种某种PPT演示，现在我们知道23世纪会发生什么。而我个人发现所有这些东西，我讨厌所有这些东西。
I think it removes all the complexity and the difference about history. It sort of basically says all history is the same. There are set rules. It's like a video game. And once you work them out, you know, you'll win. And I think it's balderdash, actually. Well, but that's the issue with lessons of history, isn't it? Is that if they're absolutely solid, then in a sense, you can't escape them. They're like a kind of straitjacket. And that we're just and I suppose that that's the idea that we're doomed to repeat the mistakes of the past.
我认为它消除了关于历史的所有复杂性和差异。它基本上说所有的历史都是一样的。有既定的规则。这就像一个电子游戏。一旦你弄清楚它们，你知道，你就会赢。而我认为那是胡说八道，实际上。好吧，但这就是历史教训的问题，不是吗？如果它们是绝对坚实的，那么在某种意义上，你无法逃避它们。它们就像一种紧身衣。而且我们只是，我想这就是我们注定要重复过去错误的观点。
What is it Karl Marx said? People make their own history, but they don't. But they make it in circumstances not of their own choosing, or words to that effect. I mean, we are prisoners of history, aren't we? But I think it's a fallacy to think that we can identify a series of a sort of formulae by which we can, by which, you know, we'll avoid the mistakes of our predecessors. I mean, patently, one lesson from history is that people don't avoid the mistakes of their predecessors. Do you know what I think? Well, I think we keep on making the same mistakes because those mistakes are kind of inevitable. Well, give them part of being human.
卡尔·马克思说了什么？人们创造他们自己的历史，但他们没有。但他们在非他们自己选择的情况下创造它，或者类似的话。我的意思是，我们是历史的囚徒，不是吗？但我认为认为我们可以识别出一系列某种公式，通过这些公式我们可以，通过这些，你知道，我们将避免我们前任的错误，这是一种谬论。我的意思是，显然，历史的一个教训是人们并没有避免他们前任的错误。你知道我在想什么吗？好吧，我认为我们不断犯同样的错误，因为那些错误是某种不可避免的。好吧，给他们作为人类的一部分。
Well, so let's look at Brexit. I feel that we haven't really touched on. I didn't see that coming. Well, so let's look at Brexit. Wow. I feel that we haven't really touched on. I didn't see that coming. So both sides in the Brexit debate say that the lesson of history is either that we should stay in the European Union or we should leave. Or we shouldn't. Yeah. Right.
好吧，所以让我们看看英国脱欧。我觉得我们还没有真正触及。我没预见到这一点。好吧，所以让我们看看英国脱欧。哇。我觉得我们还没有真正触及。我没预见到这一点。所以英国脱欧辩论中的双方都说历史的教训要么是我们应该留在欧盟，要么是我们应该离开。或者我们不应该。是的。对。
So you choose the lessons. But I would say that in that context, the lesson of history is that we were never going to be able to make our mind up. It was always going to be a kind of split because because essentially we we in Britain are the prisoner of our geography. We are. Yes. You know, can't live with continental Europe, can't live without it. So that would that for me would be a lesson of history that we're kind of doomed to repeat this push me, pull your relationship with continental Europe. And you can see that looking at the way that the course of British relationship to continental Europe, that seems to me a fairly hardcore lesson that you can draw. But I wouldn't go so far as to say the lesson is, yeah, we should leave or yeah, we should stay.
所以你选择教训。但我会说在这种背景下，历史的教训是我们永远无法下定决心。它总是会成为一种分裂，因为因为本质上我们，我们在英国是地理的囚徒。我们是。是的。你知道，不能和欧洲大陆一起生活，也不能没有它。所以对我来说，那将是历史的一个教训，我们注定要重复这种与欧洲大陆的推拉关系。你可以看到这一点，看看英国与欧洲大陆关系的进程，这对我来说似乎是一个相当硬核的教训，你可以得出。但我不会走那么远说教训是，是的，我们应该离开，或者是的，我们应该留下。
Yeah, no, I think you're right about that. I think the lesson there is not so much a lesson that gives a neat answer as a lesson that basically says it's an open question and always will be. And, you know, some listeners might not like that because they'll have very strong views about Brexit. But if you take another example, also on the European fringe, I remember reading an article a few years about Ukraine and the article said, you know, Ukraine has this choice of a European future or a Russian future. But the very nature of being Ukraine is you always have that choice and it's never resolved. And that's exactly the position with Britain and Europe. I mean, obviously, we are European and we're part of Europe. But obviously, also, there's a lot of people who don't feel European and Britain has always felt itself to be peripheral and slightly different and all the rest of it. And that's not a question that can go away. And I agree with you.
是的，不，我认为你关于这一点是对的。我认为那里的教训与其说是一个给出简洁答案的教训，不如说是一个基本上说这是一个悬而未决的问题，而且永远会是这样。而且，你知道，一些听众可能不喜欢这一点，因为他们会对英国脱欧有非常强烈的看法。但如果你采取另一个例子，也在欧洲边缘，我记得几年前读过一篇关于乌克兰的文章，文章说，你知道，乌克兰有欧洲未来或俄罗斯未来的选择。但作为乌克兰的本质是你总是拥有那个选择，而且它永远不会得到解决。而这正是英国和欧洲的情况。我的意思是，显然，我们是欧洲人，我们是欧洲的一部分。但显然，也有很多人不觉得是欧洲人，而英国一直觉得自己在边缘，稍微有点不同等等。而那不是一个可以消失的问题。我同意你的观点。
But I think what's different about that lesson is that that's a lesson that is kind of open-ended. I think where I'm suspicious of lessons from history is where they sort of shut the conversation down and they reduce it to a sort of very neat formula that miraculously coincides. Yeah. With what they think. Yeah. Political prejudices. But yes, I but but but I agree the idea of of well, I mean, you know, Joey said that the idea that history is a nightmare from which we struggle to wake up. I think that there is something there that we are stuck in
但我认为那个教训的不同之处在于，那是一个某种程度上开放式的教训。我认为我怀疑历史教训的地方是它们某种程度上关闭了对话，并将它们简化为一种非常简洁的公式，奇迹般地重合。是的。与他们所想的。是的。政治偏见。但是是的，我，但是，但是，我同意关于，好吧，我的意思是，你知道，乔伊说历史是一场我们努力醒来的噩梦。我认为那里有一些东西，我们被困在
certain contexts that we can't really break free from because of geography, because of whatever. Anyway, talking of nightmares from which we're struggling to wake up. Let's have a break. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and
某些背景中，因为地理，因为无论什么，我们无法真正摆脱。无论如何，说到我们正在努力醒来的噩梦。让我们休息一下。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的余韵》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和
early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Do please remember to rate, review, most importantly, subscribe wherever you get your podcasts. And a reminder to get in touch with us on Twitter using at the rest history. So no, there's no is in the Twitter handle. You can also contact me on at Holland underscore Tom. Or you can hassle Dominic using at DCS and Brooke, or DC Sandbrook if you want. You said that in a very strange way. Well, I just thought DCS sounded better than DC Sandbrook. I mean, DC Sandbrook, you sound like you're in The Bill or something.
抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余韵》。请务必记得评分、评论，最重要的是，在你获取播客的任何地方订阅。提醒一下，在Twitter上使用 @the rest history 与我们联系。所以不，Twitter账号里没有“is”。你也可以通过 @Holland_Tom 联系我。或者如果你想的话，你可以用 @DCSandbrook 或 DC Sandbrook 骚扰多米尼克。你刚才说得非常奇怪。好吧，我只是觉得DCS听起来比DC Sandbrook好。我的意思是，DC Sandbrook，你听起来像是在《警察故事》里或者什么。
Really? I'd never thought of that. I'd always thought that that sounded like a kind of Victorian historian who wrote like multi-volume lives of forgotten politicians but actually no yeah no you sound like a cop on the edge yeah in one of those kitchens that i go back to that's empty and is very sort of starkly lit and i eat my ready meal and contemplate the wreckage of my private life while catching the yeah while catching the serial killer yeah exactly um anyway We're slaloming off badly here. So the lesson of history is that we can't stick to the subject. So we have actually only put this up yesterday. We've had plenty of comments about it already.
真的吗？我从来没想过。我一直认为那听起来像是一个写了像被遗忘的政客的多卷本传记的维多利亚时代历史学家，但实际上不，是的，不，你听起来像是一个边缘的警察，是的，在我回去的那些厨房里，它是空的，非常严峻地照亮，我吃我的速食餐，思考我私人生活的残骸，同时抓住，是的，同时抓住连环杀手，是的，完全正确，嗯，无论如何，我们在这里严重偏离了轨道。所以历史的教训是我们无法坚持主题。所以我们实际上昨天才把这个放上去。我们已经收到了很多关于它的评论。
And for those of you who are new to the way we work, Dominic and I will tweet the subject of each pod the day before we record. So do keep a lookout on Twitter on a Thursday and do please send us your questions, your observations, indeed your corrections. All are welcome. So Dominic, what comments have we got? So let's go. We've got tons of comments, actually. So instead of us just rambling on, we should just go through them all and see how many we can get through, see if we can get through all of them. So Thomas Reyes says, he says, I feel it's a catch 22 situation where if you don't learn from history, you repeat the same mistakes.
对于那些刚接触我们工作方式的人，多米尼克和我会在我们录制前一天在Twitter上发布每期播客的主题。所以请在周四留意Twitter，并请务必发送给我们你的问题、你的观察，确实还有你的更正。都欢迎。那么多米尼克，我们有什么评论？所以让我们开始。我们实际上有大量的评论。所以与其让我们只是漫无目的地谈论，我们应该只是浏览它们，看看我们能完成多少，看看我们是否能完成所有这些。所以托马斯·雷耶斯说，他说，我觉得这是一个“第22条军规”的情况，如果你不从历史中学习，你就会重复同样的错误。
But if you do, you make some new ones. Either way, you lose. What do you think of that, Tom? Yeah, well, I think that the anxiety to avoid Munich is the classic example of that. Yes, it is. That we're, you know, politicians are so desperate not to become Chamberlain that they kind of blunder into all kinds of mistakes. Yeah. Is there not a better way of thinking about human affairs and indeed politics is to assume that you'll make mistakes? There's no way to avoid them. And you're just rather than being obsessed with the idea that there's some sort of perfection you know which if you only find the rules you'll be able to you'll be able to i mean that seems to me a very foolish way for politics i mean politicians do that don't they they they
但如果你学习了，你就会犯一些新的错误。无论哪种方式，你都输了。你对此怎么看，汤姆？是的，好吧，我认为避免慕尼黑的焦虑是那个的经典例子。是的，它是。我们，你知道，政客们如此绝望地不想成为张伯伦，以至于他们某种程度上笨拙地陷入了各种错误。是的。难道没有一种更好的思考人类事务和政治的方式是假设你会犯错误吗？没有办法避免它们。而且你只是，而不是沉迷于某种完美，你知道，如果你只找到规则，你就能，你就能，我的意思是，那对我来说似乎是一种非常愚蠢的政治方式，我的意思是，政客们那样做，不是吗？他们，他们
they pretend infallibility when they're in opposition um and then uh and then it all becomes terribly complicated when they get into office which they yeah miraculously wasn't beforehand yeah um yeah so i think this obsession with repeating mistakes i mean why don't you just assume you're going to make lots of mistakes because you're human and end of story you don't need to then read any history books ever again um doing yourself out of a job there yeah that's foolish i'll shut up okay well you thought that was a big one the next the next one is is massive and it's from chet archbold do you think we see human nature through history that transcends specific places and time? I guess that's what we were kind of fencing around in in the first half.
在反对派时假装不可战胜，嗯，然后，嗯，然后当他们上任时，一切都变得非常复杂，这，他们，是的，奇迹般地在之前没有，是的，嗯，是的，所以我认为这种对重复错误的痴迷，我的意思是，为什么你不只是假设你会犯很多错误，因为你是人类，故事结束了，你不需要再读任何历史书了，嗯，让自己失业了，是的，那很愚蠢，我会闭嘴，好吧，好吧，你认为那是一个大问题，下一个，下一个是巨大的，来自切特·阿奇博尔德，你认为我们通过历史看到了超越特定地点和时间的人性吗？我想那就是我们在上半场某种程度上在围栏周围做的事情。
And the idea that that history can be become basically a kind of a branch of science. I mean, it's been very much in the news. There's a guy in America, I think he's originally Russian, called Peter Turchin, who was a specialist in pine beetles. And he has now applied his methodology in studying pine beetles to Homo sapiens. And he's been in the news because he, I think about a decade ago, predicted that 2020 was going to be a terrible year where everything fell to pieces and he was able to arrive at this conclusion by his study of human nature and there's something very kind of science fiction about that the famous example of that is Isaac Asimov's foundation series where there's a guy called Harry Seldon who uses it to predict exactly what is going to happen in the future and his predictions do indeed hold out for, I think, several centuries, and then it all goes wrong. But it is a kind of common fantasy,
以及历史可以基本上成为某种科学分支的想法。我的意思是，它在新闻中非常多。在美国有一个人，我想他最初是俄罗斯人，叫彼得·图尔钦，他是松甲虫专家。他现在已经将他研究松甲虫的方法论应用于智人。他上了新闻，因为他，我想大约十年前，预测2020年将是可怕的一年，一切都分崩离析，他能够通过他对人性的研究得出这个结论，而且这其中有一些非常科幻的东西，著名的例子是艾萨克·阿西莫夫的《基地》系列，那里有一个叫哈里·谢尔顿的人，他用它来预测未来究竟会发生什么，而他的预测确实在，我想，几个世纪里保持有效，然后一切都出错了。但这是一种常见的幻想，
I think, the idea that if only we can identify what human nature is and apply it to the study of the past, then we can work out what the future will hold. I think we can work out what human nature is, or we can get a good sense of human nature through studying history and indeed through i mean you can get a sense of human nature through being a you know a child on a playground just looking around and history is actually not so different predicts in the future i think that's all complete balls actually um but human nature yes i think you do learn about human nature from history i mean i really do feel that reading a lot of because one of my jobs is as a you know i review a lot of history books um for the sunday times different periods so you know i'd read
我认为，如果只要我们能确定什么是人性，并将其应用于历史研究，那么我们就能推断出未来会发生什么，这种想法……我认为我们可以推断出什么是人性，或者通过研究历史，甚至通过——我的意思是，你可以通过观察游乐场里的孩子来了解人性，而历史其实也差不多，能预测未来，我觉得这完全是胡扯。嗯，但人性，是的，我认为你确实能从历史中学到关于人性的东西。我的意思是，我真的觉得读很多书——因为我的工作之一就是为《星期日泰晤士报》评论很多不同时期的历史书籍，所以你知道，我会读
dozens of books a year not on my specialism and one thing that really strikes me i mean that they have made me much more pessimistic about the human condition because in so many of these books people just behave terribly and kill each other and and all the rest of it and um i think you know studying history makes you much more it should make you more humble sort of politically you become much more aware of your own minuscule role in life's rich pageant and um gives you a sort of sense of perspective about the the issues of the day and all that kind of thing don't you think tom don't you think when you're studying the persian wars and all that's the business i what i find is is um how various and contingent human assumptions are and yes again and again where you think that there are kind of certain
一年几十本书，不是我的专业领域，有一件事真的让我印象深刻，我的意思是，它们让我对人类状况变得更加悲观，因为在这么多书中，人们的行为简直太糟糕了，互相残杀，诸如此类。嗯，我认为你知道，研究历史会让你变得更加——从政治上讲，它应该让你变得更加谦逊，你会更加意识到自己在人生这场盛大演出中微不足道的作用，嗯，这让你对当下的问题有一种视角，诸如此类，你不觉得吗，汤姆？你不觉得当你研究波斯战争以及所有这些事情时，我发现的是，人类的假设是多么多样和偶然。是的，一次又一次，当你认为存在某种
core irreducibles they turn out not to be at all, you know, attitudes to something as basic as sex or love, or it's all so culturally contingent, that that actually the kind of the idea that there is a human nature that can be redeemed from the flux of the swirl and the specificity of culture is something I don't really hold. Although having said that, I mean, I think there's this guiding principle that I think MI5 have, that Britain is four meals away from anarchy. So I think that's true. I mean, I think a lack of food. I definitely always feel that way. That kind of thing. Okay, well, that's the relationship of human nature to history dealt with in two minutes let's move we got another one maybe slightly
核心的、不可简化的东西时，结果却根本不是那样。你知道，对性或爱这样基本事物的态度，这一切在文化上都是如此偶然，以至于那种认为存在一种可以从文化的流动、漩涡和特殊性中解脱出来的人性的想法，我并不真正认同。虽然话虽如此，我的意思是，我认为军情五处有一个指导原则，即英国距离无政府状态只有四顿饭的距离。所以我认为那是真的。我的意思是，缺乏食物。我绝对一直有这种感觉。诸如此类。好吧，关于人性与历史的关系，两分钟就讲完了，我们继续，我们还有另一个，也许稍微
easier uh yes this is a much easier one always look a gift horse in the mouth says mark gourd house because there might be greek warriors inside ready to sack your city do you agree that's very good um yeah uh here's another one, particular relevance to ancient history. Mike McKay, never make your bodyguards unhappy. That's just not true of, I mean, that's not just true of, you know, Caligula or somebody, is it? It's true of... It's so true of Caligula, though. It's so true of Caligula. Of course, it is true of Caligula, but it's also true of, you know, it's true of any modern president or prime minister. Never make your courtiers, never make your associates unhappy,
容易一点。嗯，是的，这是一个容易得多的问题。马克·戈德豪斯说，永远不要去检查赠送的马的牙齿，因为里面可能有希腊战士准备洗劫你的城市。你同意吗？那非常好。嗯，是的，嗯，这里还有另一个，与古代历史特别相关。迈克·麦凯，永远不要让你的保镖不高兴。这不仅仅适用于，我的意思是，这不仅仅适用于，你知道，卡里古拉或某人，对吧？这适用于……虽然这对卡里古拉来说太真实了。这对卡里古拉来说太真实了。当然，这对卡里古拉来说是真的，但也适用于，你知道，它适用于任何现代总统或总理。永远不要让你的朝臣，永远不要让你的同僚不高兴，
and especially if they have weapons of one kind or another, they might not be literal weapons, then you're a fool to, do you need to study history to work that out? Maybe you do. Well, I mean, I suppose the difference in modern society is that
尤其是如果他们拥有某种武器，即使不是字面意义上的武器，那你就是个傻瓜。你需要研究历史才能得出这个结论吗？也许你需要。好吧，我的意思是，我想现代社会的不同之处在于
your bodyguards are more disposable because they don't have real weapons. So Boris Johnson getting rid of Dominic Cummings, lots of people think that's a good idea. Yeah. Whereas if Cummings was armed... Yeah, well, yes. I mean, Caligula laughing at his bodyguard
你的保镖更容易被替换，因为他们没有真正的武器。所以鲍里斯·约翰逊摆脱多米尼克·卡明斯，很多人认为这是个好主意。是的。然而，如果卡明斯有武装……是的，好吧，是的。我的意思是，卡里古拉嘲笑他的保镖
because he has a woman's voice. That's foolish. Because the bodyguard has a sword. So I think there's a slight difference there. Anyway. Not an eternal lesson, maybe. So now we've got I buy high and sell low. And he's got a very pessimistic lesson.
因为他有女人的声音。那是愚蠢的。因为保镖有剑。所以我认为那里有一点区别。总之。也许不是一个永恒的教训。所以现在我们有“高买低卖”。他有一个非常悲观的教训。
Nothing lasts, he or she says. Anything can become a ruin given enough time. People are just small waves on a deep, quiet river. Gosh, this is very Ozymandias, isn't it? And completely true yes nothing lasts no i mean isn't that a extraordinary thing i'll tell you what's a funny thing is how everybody assumes that um i mean people have all these kind of assumptions that they say people assume that all our current nation states for example are sort of you know they're kind of historical
他说，没有什么能持久。只要时间足够长，任何东西都会变成废墟。人们只是深邃、宁静河流上的小波浪。天哪，这非常有《奥西曼提斯》的感觉，不是吗？而且完全正确。是的，没有什么能持久。不，我的意思是，这难道不是一件非同寻常的事情吗？我告诉你一件有趣的事，就是每个人都假设——我的意思是，人们有各种各样的假设，他们说，人们假设我们所有当前的民族国家，例如，都是某种，你知道，它们是某种历史
absolutes that will last forever france door and there will always be a france and whatever one day there won't be and that a lot of people say oh how can that be true but of course nothing does last nothing at all yeah and um that's a very um religious perspective the idea that human life is brief. It comes and it goes. And by extension, human empires are brief as well. And they caught up on the flux. And there is a counterpoint to that. What's lasted longest, China, Iran?
绝对，会永远持续下去。法国，当然，总会有一个法国，无论如何，总有一天不会有了。很多人说，哦，这怎么可能是真的？但当然，没有什么能持久，什么都没有。是的，嗯，那是一个非常……宗教的视角，认为人类生命是短暂的。它来了又走。推而广之，人类帝国也是短暂的。它们被卷入了流动之中。对此有一个对立的观点。什么持续时间最长？中国，伊朗？
Yeah, I think China is the kind of the great countercultural example to the assumption that we have in the West that empires rise and are destined to fall. Because although China has repeatedly receded and been conquered and seemed to fall apart, it's always reconstituted itself. As we were talking about earlier, it's always absorbed those who conquer it. And I think you can recognise that China in the 21st century is very much an empire in the way that it was back in the days of the first emperor. So in that sense, you could say, well, you know, China lasts. Yes, maybe anything. Nothing is inevitable, except for death taxes and the Chinese empire. Okay, here's a more specific point from Francis Stratford. You don't think the Germans will invade neutral Belgium a second time, do you? Okay, that's an interesting point, because actually, that does take us back again to
是的，我认为中国是那种反文化的例子，反驳了我们在西方所持有的那种帝国兴起并注定衰落的假设。因为虽然中国多次衰落、被征服并似乎分崩离析，但它总是能重组自己。正如我们之前谈到的，它总是吸收那些征服它的人。我认为你可以认识到，21世纪的中国在很大程度上是一个帝国，就像它在第一位皇帝时期那样。所以从这个意义上说，你可以说，嗯，你知道，中国持久。是的，也许任何事情。除了死亡、税收和中华帝国，没有什么是不可能的。好吧，这里有一个来自弗朗西斯·斯特拉特福德的更具体的观点。你不认为德国人会第二次入侵中立的比利时，对吧？好吧，这是一个有趣的观点，因为实际上，这确实让我们回到了
the way that geography kind of channels events over and over again. And the way in which what is now Belgium, but was, you know, for a long time, just the low countries and the way in which what is now Belgium but was you know for a long time just the low countries the way that that has kind of been a stamping ground I suppose for the rival powers in Germany and France I mean that has been a kind of constant hasn't it? Yes and that's true actually and I think it's a weird thing how historians often don't take enough account of geography I did a I mean this is back years, but I did a course when I was an undergraduate about the Near East in the age of Justinian and Muhammad. And in the very first tutorial, my tutor said, you know, just he got out this big atlas and we looked at the map and he said, it's really important that you know,
地理在一次又一次地引导事件的方式。以及现在被称为比利时，但长期以来只是低地国家的地方，以及现在被称为比利时，但长期以来只是低地国家的地方，它一直是一个竞争的场所，我想，对于德国和法国的竞争势力来说。我的意思是，那一直是一种常态，不是吗？是的，这确实是真的。而且我认为很奇怪，历史学家往往没有充分考虑地理因素。我做过一个——我的意思是，这是几年前的事了，但我本科时上过一门关于查士丁尼和穆罕默德时代的近东课程。在第一次辅导课上，我的导师说，你知道，他拿出一张大地图集，我们看了地图，他说，了解山脉在哪里、你要去哪里行军、城市在哪里，所有这些事情，真的很重要。很多事情实际上历史学家，特别是现代历史学家，并没有真正给予足够的重视。我们是地理的囚徒。在某种程度上，我的意思是，我们在历史中试图寻找的模式往往与人类行为无关。它们实际上是我们星球如何制约我们的行为。我认为比利时就是一个很好的例子。但关于比利时的事情，它更多是地缘政治的，而不仅仅是地理的，不是吗？我的意思是，它是成为法国和成为德国之间的断裂线，
like where the mountains are, where you're going to march, where the cities are, all this kind of thing. Lots of things that actually historians, particularly modern historians, don't really take massive account of. And we are prisoners of geography. And to that extent, I mean, the patterns that we seek to find in history are often not to do with human behaviour. They're how actually our planet conditions how we behave. And I think Belgium is a good example of that. But the thing about Belgium is kind of it's more a geopolitical than just a geographical one, isn't it? I mean, it's the kind of the fracture line between what becomes France and what becomes Germany,
我想这真的可以追溯到查理曼大帝时代，以及……确实如此。有一本关于这个的书，不是吗？洛泰尔王国。所以当查理曼大帝，你知道，查理曼大帝的遗产被分成三部分时，你所说的，你知道，荷兰、比利时、瑞士等等，这个中央地带。是的，勃艮第，没错。这个中央地带一直是一个边界区。我们之前谈到了乌克兰，乌克兰实际上就是一个很好的例子，欧洲和俄罗斯之间的这种边境地带。而俄罗斯自己的，
which I suppose really goes back to Charlemagne's time and the... It does. There's a book about this, isn't there? Lopharingia. So when Charlemagne, you know, Charlemagne's inheritance gets divided into three parts, and what you'd call, you know, the Netherlands, Belgium, Switzerland and whatnot, this sort of central belt. Yeah, Burgundy, exactly. This sort of central belt has always been a border zone. And we talked about Ukraine earlier, and Ukraine's a good example of that, actually, this sort of borderland between Europe and Russia. And Russia's own,
你知道，如果你不了解地理，你就无法理解俄罗斯的历史，或者弗拉基米尔·普京现在正在做出的决定。我想波兰在历史上也是如此。波兰一直被争夺、分裂等等。我想这是支持欧盟的一个关键论点，即它在某种程度上是为了解决洛泰尔王国、比利时和勃艮第等问题而设计的，为了阻止法国和德国争夺阿尔萨斯-洛林。所以也许这就是，你知道，这是历史的一个教训，你需要欧盟来阻止人们为此打仗。
you know, you can't understand Russian history without, or the decisions that Vladimir Putin is taking right now, you can't understand them if you don't understand the geography. And the same would be true of Poland, I guess, historically. Poland's been kind of fought over, split apart, whatever. And I guess that's a key argument in favour of the European Union, is that it, in a way, was kind of designed to solve the problem of Lotharingia, Belgium and Burgundy, and that kind of stuff, to stop France and Germany fighting over Alsace-Lorraine. So maybe that is, you know, that's a lesson from history, is you need the European Union to stop people fighting over it.
汤姆，那是一个非常浪漫的观点。我相信我们可以提出其他的教训来反驳这一点。这里有一个来自艾伦·斯米顿的。他说，历史学家在事实是什么、对所述事实的解释以及可以从中得出的结论方面，被预先设定为激烈地相互争论。我想这意味着甚至在什么是事实的问题上都存在分歧。嗯，确实存在，不是吗？
Very romantic point there, Tom. I'm sure there are alternative lessons that we could come up with to oppose that. Here's one from Alan Smeaton. And he says, historians are pre-programmed to vehemently disagree with one another when it comes to what are facts, the interpretation of said facts, and the conclusions that can be drawn from them. And I guess the implication of that is that there's a kind of disagreement as to even what constitutes a fact. Well, there is, isn't there?
以及事实的重要性。是的，我认为这绝对正确。而且我认为历史学家确实会相互争论。我的意思是，历史学家并不……有时有一种观点认为历史学家相互争论是因为他们异常刻薄、以自我为中心，并且嫉妒他们的领地。但历史学家对过去有分歧是因为他们是人，
And the significance of a fact. Yeah, I think that's absolutely right. And I think that historians do disagree with one another. I mean, historians don't... There's sometimes a view that historians disagree with each other because they're sort of unusually sort of bitter and self-centred and jealous of their territory. But historians disagree with each other about the past because they're human,
因为我们所有人对任何事情都有分歧，特别是对过去，实际上。所以，你知道，历史学家对过去有分歧，不仅仅是因为某种职业的、行业的原因，而是因为如果你让两个人对某个特定时刻进行描述，他们总是会给你两个不同的版本。这就是历史的魅力，不是吗？没有所谓的答案或单一的解释，实际上这就是我们喜欢它的原因，而且教训不一定
because we all disagree with each other about everything, and particularly about the past, actually. So, you know, historians disagree with each other about the past not just for sort of professional, industrial reasons, but because if you ask two people to give an account of a given moment, they'll always give you two different versions. And that's the beauty of history isn't it that there isn't ever an answer or a single explanation and actually that's why we like it and lessons are don't necessarily have
必须是真实的，这也是非常重要的一点，要记住教训是可以被教授的，而且它们可能是完全错误的。是的，人们可能会走过来说，嗯，实际上，这不是我想要的教训，我想要一个不同的教训。是的。好吧，绥靖政策的例子就是这方面的经典例子，绥靖政策的教训建立在对20世纪30年代发生的事情的一种非常简单的理解之上，
to be true that's also something very important to bear in mind that lessons can be taught and they can be completely wrong yeah and people can come along and say, well, actually, this isn't the lesson I want to, I want a different lesson. Yeah. Well, the appeasement example is the classic example of that, that the appeasement lesson rests upon a sort of very simplistic understanding of what happened in the 1930s,
但这并不能阻止人们。我的意思是，人们永远不会停止谈论它，不是吗？我的意思是，他们会永远谈论下去。可怜的张伯伦。是的。看，我喜欢张伯伦，我觉得他被冤枉了。是的，米德兰人，是的，就像你自己一样，是的，太棒了。嗯，我们在历史上经历过糟糕的待遇，除了莎士比亚。总之，我现在只是在胡言乱语。
but doesn't stop people. I mean, people will never shut up about it, will they? I mean, they'll go on about it forever. Poor Chamberlain. Yeah. See, I like chamberlain i think he's uh hard done by yeah midlander yes exactly like yourself yes great um we've we've had a rough deal midlanders in history except for shakespeare anyway i'm just rambling now
艾伦·奥尔波特，艾伦·奥尔波特说，他说，嗯，这对我来说只是一个发泄我不安的工具。艾伦·奥尔波特说，正如我告诉我的学生的那样，那些不能从历史中吸取教训的人注定要重考。现在，艾伦·奥尔波特是一本非常好的第二次世界大战历史的作者，嗯，辉煌的第二次世界大战历史，以托尔金开头，所有历史都应该这样。那些不能从历史中吸取教训的人注定要重考。这是真的吗？我的意思是，这是一个不错的笑话，但它也包含了那种关于
alan allport alan allport says he says um this is just a sort of vehicle now for me to air my my insecurities alan allport says as i tell my students those who fail to learn from history are doomed to repeat the exam now alan allport is the author of a very good uh history of the second world war um brilliant history the second world which kicks off with tolkien which all histories should um those who fail to learn from history are doomed to repeat the exam. Is that true? I mean, that's a nice joke, but it's also that idea about
如果你不从历史中学习，你就会重复它。我实际上甚至不相信这一点。我认为无论你是否从中学习，你都会犯错误。但其中也埋藏着一种假设，即存在某种确定的学术范式，
if you don't learn from history, you'll repeat it. I actually don't even believe that. I think you'll make mistakes whether you learn from it or not. But there's also buried there the assumption that there is a kind of certain scholarly paradigm
如果你不认同它，那么你就会遇到麻烦。而且，你知道，有些历史学家非常伟大，以至于他们偶尔会出现并打破那种范式。而且你可以，你知道，你可以完全不及格，因为你没有给出正确的答案。但实际上，你的答案可能比考官期望的传统答案更有趣。这就是我考试不及格时一直希望的，你知道。你会得到历史的平反。是的，我会得到历史的平反。
that if you don't subscribe to it, then you will get in trouble. And, you know, there are historians who are so great that every so often they will come along and they will shatter that paradigm. And you could, you know, you could completely fail the exam because you don't give the right answer. But actually, your answer could be more interesting than the conventional one that's expected by the examiners. That's always what I kind of hoped, you know, when I failed an exam. You'll be vindicated by history. Yeah, I'll be vindicated by history.
好的，这里有一个来自凯文·奥布莱恩·张的。用四句话概括历史的所有教训。这太棒了。神欲使其灭亡，必先使其疯狂。上帝的磨盘磨得很慢，但磨得极细。蜜蜂在采蜜时也会授粉。当足够黑暗时，你就能看到星星。天哪，嗯，查尔斯·比尔德的这段引言，这是——这是来自查尔斯·比尔德吗？某种美国马克思主义历史学家。我不知道。
OK, here we've got one from Kevin O'Brien Chang. All the lessons of history in four sentences. This is great stuff. Whom the gods would destroy, they first make mad with power. power the mills of god grind slowly but they grind exceedingly small the bee fertilizes the flower it robs when it is dark enough you can see the stars golly um this quotation from charles a beard is this i'm is that from charles a beard sort of american mar Marxist historian. I don't know.
当足够黑暗时，你就能看到星星。这听起来有点像贺卡上的话，不是吗？我的意思是，你寄……相当令人沮丧的贺卡。是的，但你的一个朋友在医院。我寄给他们这个。期待你收到那种欢快情绪的圣诞贺卡。不，不，因为我只是不相信你能看到星星。
When it's dark enough, you can see the stars. That sounds like a little bit like something from a greetings card, doesn't it? I mean, you send... Quite a depressive greetings card. Yeah, but a friend of yours is in hospital. I sent them this. Look forward to your Christmas card with that kind of cheery sentiment. No, no, because I just don't believe you can see the stars.
所以我认为，我认为当时足够黑暗。你知道，只是更多的黑暗。是的。好吧，嗯，我对人类事务有一种非常凄凉的感觉。你确实有。好吧，这里有一个绝对正确的。卡尔·格洛弗说，永远不要卷入亚洲的陆地战争。这绝对正确，因为那是《公主新娘》里的台词。但我认为伟大的——他在亚洲赢得了他所有的战争。多米尼克，别说了。
So I think I think it was dark enough. You know, just more darkness. Yeah. OK, well, I've got a very bleak sense of human affairs. You certainly have. Well, here's one that's definitely right. Carl Glover says never get involved in a land war in Asia. And that's definitely right, because that's in The Princess Bride. But I think the great he won all his wars in Asia. Dominic, stop it.
《公主新娘》是对的。而且还有永远不要在生死关头与西西里人作对。那是《公主新娘》提供的另一个历史教训。我认为……亚洲的陆地战争。永远不要卷入亚洲的陆地战争。当然，你是对的。我的意思是，你知道，亚洲有很多征服者。但我认为意思是不要入侵那些你会陷入泥潭的亚洲地区。越南就是一个例子。但从……从大局来看，这基本上是对入侵叙利亚、蒙古、俄罗斯的警告。你知道，草原，欧亚大陆的广阔，阿富汗。是的。我的意思是，就是这样。所以英国人在19世纪进入了阿富汗，不是吗？
The Princess Bride is right. And also that there's also never go against the Sicilian when death is on the line. That's the other lesson from history that Princess Bride has to offer. I think the... Land war in Asia. Never get involved in a land war in Asia. Of course, you're right. I mean, you know, lots of conquerors in Asia. But I suppose the sense is don't invade areas of Asia where you are going to get bogged down. And Vietnam would be the example. But over the course of, you know, over the board sweep, basically, it's a warning against invading Syria, Mongolia, Russia. You know, the steppes, the vastness of Eurasia, Afghanistan. Yes. I mean, that's it. So the British went into Afghanistan in the 19th century, didn't they?
为了试图确保印度西北边境的安全，嗯，俄罗斯人在1980年代显然进入了，然后是2001年之后的联军，他们都以各种方式以糟糕的结局告终。嗯，这可能是一个很好的例子。人们经常说，为什么外交部或国务院里没有人真正精通19世纪的英国历史？但实际上，战争往往是因为，因为它们往往正是你刚才谈到的那些人，他们去过西点军校，花了三年时间研究所有这些古代战争等等。所以，是的，但我的意思是，而且俄罗斯也是一个大问题，不是吗？所以你有大流士大帝入侵斯基泰，结果是一场灾难。
To try and secure the border northwest border of india um the russians obviously went into in the 1980s and then the coalition after 2001 and they all ended badly in various ways um and that is probably a good example people often sort of said why isn't there someone in the foreign office or the state department who's really au fait with you know 19th century british history but actually often the wars, because often they were precisely these people that you were talking about earlier, who'd been to West Point and sort of spent, you know, three years studying all these sort of ancient wars and whatnot. So, yeah, but I mean, and also Russia is the big one, isn't it? So you've got Darius the Great who invades Scythia and it goes disastrous.
他是第一个。然后著名的是拿破仑，然后你有大流士大帝入侵斯基泰，结果是一场灾难。他是第一个。然后著名的是拿破仑，然后你有希特勒。是的，我的意思是，关于这一点非同寻常的是，希特勒犯了和拿破仑完全一样的错误，不是吗？再次充满了傲慢。所以这又是你的傲慢教训。而且这只是糟糕的冬季计划，不是吗？和其他任何事情一样。多米尼克，你玩过《风险》吗？是的，当然。好的，所以《风险》。是的，这是一个全球征服的游戏。是的，诱惑总是试图征服亚洲，它总是摧毁你。所以应用于《风险》的历史教训，我想我玩过一个叫《钢铁雄心》的游戏，一个叫《钢铁雄心》的策略游戏，我在第二次世界大战中扮演德国，我确实入侵了俄罗斯，因为我决心在别人失败的地方取得成功，但我失败了。你做得怎么样？灾难性的，灾难性的。你到斯大林格勒了吗？我想我甚至没走那么远，我想我被彻底歼灭了。好的，所以不要入侵俄罗斯，我的意思是，这是一个历史教训，如果连我都做不到，那任何人都没有希望了。好的，这里有一个绝对适合你的，正合你意。
He's the first. And then famously you've got Napoleon and then you've got Darius the Great who invades Scythia and it goes disastrous. He's the first. And then famously you've got Napoleon and then you've got Hitler. Yeah, I mean, the extraordinary thing about that is Hitler makes exactly the same mistake as Napoleon, doesn't he? Again, suffused with hubris. So that's your hubris lesson again. And that's just poor winter planning, isn't it? As much as anything. Have you, Dominic, have you ever played Risk? Yes, of course. Okay, so Risk. Yeah. poor winter planning isn't it as much as anything have you dominic you ever played risk yes of
克尚克的历史。掩盖真相总是比最初的罪行更糟糕。例如，尼克松和水门事件。而你是尼克松先生。是的。所以这对水门事件绝对适用，因为水门事件在许多方面只是一场小丑般的闹剧，并没有真正奏效。它没有改变选举结果。如果尼克松的人承认他们以这种非常无能的方式窃听了民主党总部，他们实际上可能已经逃脱了惩罚。我当然认为尼克松本人本可以逃脱惩罚。但正是掩盖真相，然后是关于他有这种录音系统并且一直在录音的揭露，
course okay so risk yeah it's a game of global conquest yeah and the temptation is always to try and conquer asia and it always destroys you so the lesson of history applied to risk i think i've played a game called hearts of iron a strategy game called hearts of iron where i played as germany in the second world war and i did invade russia because i was determined to um succeed where others had failed and i failed how did you do disastrous disastrous did you get to stalingrad i don't think even think i got that far i think i was just utterly annihilated okay so don't don't invade russia i mean that's a lesson of history if even i can't do it then there's no hope for anybody. OK, well, here's one definitely for you, right up your street.
以及关于他在录音带上所说内容的揭露。而且事实是它持续了一年多，这才是真正让他完蛋的原因。所以他是掩盖真相最终吞噬你的一个经典例子。我想，作为一个教训，这取决于最初的罪行是什么，不是吗？是的，因为我们可能永远不知道这个罪行，在这种情况下，掩盖真相实际上是有效的。
Kshank's history. The cover-up is always worse than the original crime. For example, Nixon and Watergate. And you are Mr Nixon. Yes. So that's definitely true of Watergate, because Watergate was in many ways just a sort of clownish escapade that didn't really work. It didn't change the election result. Had Nixon's men confessed that they'd bugged the Democratic headquarters in this very incompetent way, they would probably have been able to get away with it, actually. I certainly think Nixon himself would have been able to get away with it. But it was the cover-up and then the revelations that he had this taping system and he'd been recording himself,
也许历史上充斥着我们甚至不知道的成功掩盖。这总是人们打开档案的乐趣，不是吗？是发现你希望发现一些可怕的东西。但这从未发生过，不是吗？我的意思是，实际上如果发生了，那将是辉煌的。
and then the revelations of what he'd been saying on the tapes. And the fact that it was so protracted over more than a year, that's what really did for him. So he's a classic example of the cover-up kind of consuming you. I suppose, as a lesson, it depends what the original crime is, isn't it? Yeah, because it may well be that we never know about the crime, in which case the cover-up actually works.
但是的，我认为这很奇怪，不是吗？政客们不愿道歉。我认为这是历史的一个教训。一个快速的、某种幽默的、谦逊的道歉将解决许多问题。但人们不喜欢这样做。好吧，多米尼克的公关建议。
Maybe history is littered with successful cover-ups that we don't even know about. That's always the fun of people opening archives, isn't it? Is discovering the hope that you'll discover something terrible. It never happens though, does it? I mean, actually if it did it'd be brilliant.
我希望有很多政客在听，他们可能想采用他的指导。好吧，我们说过这是一个大问题，你知道，历史有教训吗？事实证明确实如此。请务必保持联系。告诉我们你从历史中吸取的教训，我们下周会读出最好的五个。提醒一下，请评分、评论和订阅。衷心感谢所有已经这样做的朋友。我们下周回来。到时候见。再次感谢收听。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如需额外剧集、抢先体验、无广告收听和访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。
But yes, I think it's strange, isn't it? Politicians' reluctance to apologise. I think that is a lesson from history. A quick, sort of humorous, humble apology will solve a multitude of problems. But people don't like doing it. Well, spin doctoring advice there from Dominic.
那是 restishistorypod.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
And I hope that there are lots of politicians listening who may want to employ his guidance. Well, we said it was a big question, you know, are there lessons from history? And so it has proved to be. Please do get in touch. Tell us if you have lessons that you draw from history and we'll read out the best five next week. A reminder, please, to rate, review and subscribe. And a hearty thanks to everyone who has kindly done so already. We'll be back next week. See you then. Thanks again for listening. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
我希望有很多政治家正在收听，他们或许会想要采纳他的指导。嗯，我们说过这是一个宏大的问题，你知道，历史能给我们带来什么教训吗？事实证明确实如此。请务必与我们联系。告诉我们你从历史中汲取的教训，下周我们将选出最好的五条读出来。再次提醒大家，请评分、评论并订阅。衷心感谢每一位已经这样做的听众。我们下周见。到时候见。再次感谢大家的收听。感谢收听《历史的余味》。如需收听奖励剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。